GENIUSES LIKE TORI AND NEWLAND,
THEY CONSIDER THE EFFECTS MARK
MAYBE THEY HAVE TULSI GABBARD AS
A FORMER MEMBER OF CONGRESS FROM
HAWAII WHO FROM THE VERY FIRST
DAY, FROM FEBRUARY 24 WHEN THE
WAR BEGAN, HAS BEEN SAYING THE
SAME THING, WHICH IS THE STAKES
ARE HIGH, MAYBE WE SHOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BEFORE WE
PROCEED.
CONGRESSWOMAN THANKS FOR COMING
ON.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> WERE REMINDED ONCE AGAIN TO
RECORD THAT WE ARE UNFORTUNATELY
BEING LED BY LEADERS WHO ARE
SELFISH AND SORT SIGN IT AND
DON'T CARE ABOUT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THEY'RE LEADING US FURTHER AND
FURTHER INTO WAR WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING ONE OF THE MOST
BASIC TENETS AND CHARACTERISTICS
OF WAR WHICH IS THAT IT'S
UNPREDICTABLE.
ONCE THAT FIRST SHOT IS FIRED,
ONCE THE FIRST PUNCHES THROWN,
THE PREDICTABLE NATURE OF
THINGS, YOU CAN PLAN FOR THINGS,
BUT IT BY NATURE BECOMES
UNPREDICTABLE.
SO THE LIKE, OH, MY GOSH, THIS
IS BECOME SABOTAGE.
WELL, YEAH.
WAR IS UNPREDICTABLE.
WHAT'S NOT UNPREDICTABLE IS THE
COST OF WAR.
THE SUFFERING, THE DEVASTATION,
DESTRUCTION, THE DEATH THAT IS
CAUSED BY IT.
SO THE QUESTION FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE IS HOW MUCH SUFFERING
WE'LL HAVE TO TO ENDURE HERE IN
THIS COUNTRY AND FOR PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD?
BECAUSE AS YOU CLEARLY STATED,
WE SEE HIS SABOTAGE OF AN ENERGY
PIPELINE TODAY.
WHAT'S NEXT?
ACCESS TO?
SATELLITES THAT ARE CONNECTED TO
GPS THE POWER ALL PARTS OF OUR
LIFE INCLUDING OUR WEAPON
SYSTEMS?
GO DOWN THE LINE WE END UP WITH
THIS POTENTIAL NUCLEAR OUTCOME
RADAR LEADERS ARE SAYING WE
CAN'T DO ANYTHING, THIS IS
IMPORTANT SANDS.
BUT OUR LEADERS AND EUROPEAN
LEADERS ARE THE ONES FEELING IN
FUNDING THIS WORK.
THEY HAVE A HECK OF A LOT OF
LEVERAGE TO BE ABLE TO PUSH FOR
A CEASE-FIRE, A NEGOTIATED
CEASE-FIRE AND FIGHT FOR PEACE
AND PROSPERITY.
WE NEED TO KNOW THAT IF THEY'RE
NOT DOING THAT, AND THEY AREN'T
RIGHT NOW, THAN WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS PUSHING FOR MORE
DESTRUCTION, MORE WAR, AND
THEREFORE LACK OF PEACE AND
PROSPERITY.
>> Tucker: IF IT TURNS OUT
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ACTUALLY BLEW UP A NATURAL GAS
LINE, OR OKAYED SOMEONE ELSE'S
SABOTAGE OF THE PIPELINE,
SHOULDN'T BE A FEDERAL LAW THAT
PREVENTS US FROM LECTURING US
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE OF AGAIN?
SPEAKING I DON'T HAVE THE
EVIDENCE OF WHO IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS.
THERE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES IF
THAT IS EVER FOUND OUT.
BUT WE HAVE THE REALITY OF WHAT
WERE DEALING WITH RIGHT BEFORE
US TODAY, WHICH IS, IF HE
CONTINUED DOWN THIS PATH, WE MAY
END UP WITH A NUCLEAR HOLOCAUST.
SO FOR US AND MILLIONS AROUND
THE WORLD, WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
DO ABOUT IT?
WE NEED TO CALL IN OUR LEADERS
TO TAKE A STAND AND FIGHT FOR
PEACE, FIGHT FOR PROSPERITY, OUR
FUTURE.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
YOU'D KIND OF LIKE YOUR KIDS TO
BE ABLE TO GROW UP A